ما تقوله وما تقوله كان ينبغي الاستفادة منه
لماذا يستخدم هذا الحدث للعودة واحتلال غزة؟
وإعادة زرع المستوطنات اليهودية في الكتلة
تيف بالطبع
جار
[موسيقى]
ك
فترة مظلمة وبائسة وكانت ذروتها بالطبع
في التهجير نفسه، في محو المستوطنات
في التراجع عن إرهابيي الوطن
فترتنا
الظلام في تاريخ دولة إسرائيل وما نحن عليه
نلتقي اليوم نلتقي بإذن الله
بالعكس، نلتقي بحكومة عازمة على التشريع
بالفعل في الأيام المقبلة قانون الخمسة هو
القانون الأول الذي يقول أننا نصحح الخطيئة
فك الارتباط والعودة إلى حبال الأرض التي تخلت عنهم
وإلى المستوطنات هذا السيف
لا أعرف كم سنة مضت على هذا الحال، للأسف
لدابوني لادافون كلنا نرجع لهاميل غزة ستكون
ينطوي على العديد من التضحيات وكذلك العظام
رحيلك روح في كثير من الضحايا ولكن
ليس هناك شك في أنها في نهاية ذلك اليوم كانت جزءًا من البلاد
إسرائيل ستعيش اليوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ب